So at this point, once the kernel has
doctored this client thread to start executing the
server procedure, it can transfer control to the
server. So it transfers the control to the
server, and so now, now we're starting to
execute the server procedure in the server's address
space. And in the server's address space because
A-stack has been mapped in, this is also available
to the server domain. And the first thing
that's going to happen in the server domain is
our server stub is going to get into action
and take the arguments that are sitting in
the A-stack, and copy them into the stack
that the server procedure's going to use. Remember I
told you the kernel provides a special stack
for the purpose an E- stack, execution stack and
that is a stack into which the client,
the server stub is going to copy the A-stack
argument into that E-stack and then at that
point the procedure foo is ready start executing.
So at this point, procedure foo is like
any normal procedure, it finds the information it
wants on the stack, it does its job.
Once it is done with executing this procedure,
it has to pass back the results to the client and what is going to happen is
that the server stub is going to take the results
of this procedure execution and copy them into the
A-stack. And of course, all of this action is
happening in the server domain without any mediation by
the kernel. So once the server stub has copied
the results into the A-stack, at that point it
can trap into the kernel, and this is
the vehicle by which the kernel can transfer control
back to the client so it, it does a
return trap. Now, when this return trap happens, there
is no need for the kernel to validate this
trap as opposed to the call trap, because the
up call was made by the kernel in the
very first place, and therefore it is expecting this
return trap to happen, and so the kernel doesn't have
to do any special validation for this. And at this point,
what the kernel is going to do, is it is basically
going to re-doctor the thread to start executing the client address
space. So basically it knows the return address where it has
to go back in order to start executing the client code,
and it knows the client's address space so it's going to
redoctor the thread to start executing in the client address space.
So when the client thread is rescheduled to
execute, at that point, the client stub gets
back into action, copies the results that are
sitting in the A-stack into the stack of the
client, and once it has done that, the
client thread can continue on with its normal execution.
So that's what is going on. And the
important point that you notice is that the copying
through the kernel that used to happen
is now completely eliminated, because your arguments are
passed through the A-stack into the server. And
similarly the result is passed through the A-stack
into the client. So let's analyze what we've
accomplished in terms of reducing the cost of
the RPC in the actual calls that are
being made between the client and the server.